-Dozens of men
in powerful positions
have been accused
of sexual harassment lately,
and many of them
have made public apologies.
Here to comment
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi!
-Hi, Amber!
-Hi, Seth!
Now, Seth, I've heard a lot
of men apologizing lately.
And I want to talk about
how those apologies
have inspired me,
and what I've learned from them.
[ Thwak! ]
[ Laughter ]
-You just...
You just punched me in the face.
-I categorically
deny those allegations.
[ Laughter ]
-Amber...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You just punched me.
-Did I?
That doesn't sound like me.
[ Laughter ]
Anyone who knows me
would say
that's very out of character.
-Amber, you came out here,
you sat down,
and you punched me in the face!
-I remember those events
differently.
-Amber!
-I'm sorry...
that your face feels punched.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not an apology.
-Seth, it was
a different time back then.
[ Laughter ]
-It was 30 seconds ago!
And you punched me in the face!
-Me?
Punch someone in the face?
Look, I've always been
a supporter of faces.
[ Laughter ]
Some of my best friends
have faces.
[ Laughter ]
-Amber, you punched me
in the face.
It's wrong,
and when we do something wrong,
the right thing to do
is apologize clearly
and sincerely
and without caveat.
-You're right.
[ Breathes deeply ]
I did punch Seth Meyers
in the face, and I am sorry.
I guess
I was hesitant to apologize,
because then everyone would know
that I'm a dirty face-puncher.
[ Laughter ]
And now, because people
know I'm a face-puncher,
there are certain jobs
that I just can't have,
like movie producer
or "Today Show" host
or Senator from Minnesota.
[ Laughter ]
But I can still
be a Senator from Alabama!
Vote Amber Ruffin, baby!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.